let's talk stocks you ready to talk
stocks look if you're into individual
stocks this segment is for you and i
talked about i don't give financial
advice i don't do stock picking i did
give you financial advice on you know
not buying 15
slice of pizza so let me give you the
disclaimer i'm not telling you to buy
these stocks or not buy these stocks i'm
just making you aware of what's going on
out there
so the motley fool very reputable
financial stock picking guru
um outlet
the motley fool talks about three
potential winning stocks
that you can benefit from
from
biden's infrastructure plan whether
you're a fan of biden whether you're
anti-biden whatever whatever the cards
the show goes on right the show goes on
we're talking infrastructure right the
congress looks like they're gonna be
passing this multi-trillion dollar
infrastructure deal how can you take
advantage of it right rather than
arguing oh there's that should they do
it how could you take advantage of it
here are three stocks that you should be
aware of
number one
brookfield renewable they're on the new
york stock exchange under bep
bepp
they have a large development pipeline
of projects in the u.s a large
development pipeline of projects in the
u.s that's number one brookfield
renewable renewable energy right green
energy renewable that's a stock you can
look into rogers that's number two
they're on the new york stock exchange
under rog how fitting
rogers right yeah um they provide key
components to the electric vehicle and
renewable energy industries so we got
renewable energy we got electric
vehicles sensing a theme here and then
we got number three vulcan
vulcan on a new york stock exchange
under vmc they do asphalt concrete that
will all be in high demand if the
legislation passes albeit which it looks
like it will anyway what's the bottom
line what's the lesson here tell me
our government
the show goes on whether you're on the
left or the right doesn't matter this
show is all about the green but there's
going to be opportunities to take
advantage of what the government is
planning on doing yes these companies
are not household names
but the opportunities are out there to
take advantage of them okay i'm not
saying that you should buy these stocks
or
not buy these stocks i'm saying that's
this what this article is about to keep
an eye on full disclosure bro yeah i'm
not an individual stock guy i haven't
known you to be one i'm more of a
mutual fund yeah index fund
max out my 401k every year contribute to
my roth ira when i can have a roth ira
you know sometimes i'll maybe dabble in
individual stocks but there's a lot of
risk reward with that anyway look into
it that's what's going out there in the
atmosphere you're gonna start to see a
lot more
uh news out there
about biden's infrastructure deals so
maybe if you're a stock person boom
that's just a little advice that you can
tap into but basically electric green
infrastructure these are all things that
are gonna be in high demand
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken